all right welcome everybody so glad that
you were able to join me we're going to
have a good time today at least as good
a time
as we can have as we watch a
a super-spreading group of clowns cheer
the non-sequitur lunacy of a
recently coveted positive president
within that situation
we're going to have absolutely as much
fun as
humanly possible so that is the news yes
it is columbus day indigenous people's
day
i was away all weekend we were off today
from the broadcast
show as we call it um but i do want to
see what kind of
shape donald trump is in here i predict
it will be really weird yeah as people
are saying
in in the chat i think it's going to be
really really weird
i've showered for this one my hair is is
um
you know it's it's my hair i mean what
can i say i have
all sorts of different powerful elements
down below
that i'm going to be showing you some
are um
well i have different things i'm not
even going to get why do i get ahead of
it i won't i will also
by the way be debuting a
new single from joe woodward which not
only is a trump single
it now includes samples of my own
voice as well so it's going to be
it's going to be incredible we've got a
great stream here i maybe have some
clips for you guys
i'm going to reveal a few other things
that are going on and it's going to be
great so i'm really glad that
everybody's here
of course you may or may not have heard
that there is no second debate the
second debate has been canceled
initially because of captain kovid
they said it would be a remote debate on
thursday night
then captain covid said i'm not doing
remote anybody could silence me
so then it was a 90 it was just a talent
they gave a town hall to joe biden
and then i guess now the debate has been
officially canceled and trump is
considering doing a different town hall
on a different network hopefully the
town halls will not be concurrent it
will be one after the other
and then i'd be here and and we will
cover them but there will be other
rallies this week joe biden has some
events this week
there's gonna be no shortage of events
this week all right so let's get
everything
straightened out one thing at a time do
we have audio here
we do okay yeah very very good so we
have audio for when
for when the time comes we're also
standing by on a oh we have the fox news
feed let's see if we have audio there
yep macho man is very very strongly
playing so
all of w we're ready there let me before
we go any further because i have other
things
to show you guys i want to let more
people join
okay so i wanna fur let me just start by
reading some super chats which i would
love for you to send if you're watching
on youtube it's a beautiful day for a
super chat
uh chakuseki says i'm worried amy coved
barrett and cobbfe19
will finally convert us into a
taliban-esque trump ministan
we need to vote the prompt plague out
yeah
trump is back people want trump a
democratic brotherhood of saint nicholas
says
who's betting trump goes to the hospital
next week yeah i mean that listen that
could happen some people do have a sort
of second
um second wave as uh for lack of a
better term
and they end up in the hospital that
would be very bad
for trump danny thompson says thanks for
covering this event
today as i know you were planning to
take this indigenous people's day off
your voice in this left space is so
needed that this pacmaniac appreciates
all you do
yeah when i but just so people know when
i say we're off it means there's no
podcast or
radio show or tv show or free speech tv
show
but uh i got back a few hours ago from
from a beautiful weekend i'll even have
some pictures for you relevant pictures
from the weekend
and um we are live we are live right now
this is not a rerun
alexander says if biden wins with a
landslide can the conservative supreme
court still just hand trump the
presidency
it would be pretty damn difficult which
is why i think we should
win by a landslide and one of the
elements i have here is
is related to that turtle fuzzle
i'm sorry no turtle fuzzle says shout
out to david and all my lgbt comrades
very nice michael dahl says david is
there any collective action that we
could take in the event that you were
detained for your obviously illegal
membership discounts
hey i have something great for you guys
this is i'm going to read to you a story
of the risks of taking advantage of one
of my dangerous
membership discounts look at this
horrible story
the police pulled me over after i became
a member this is from the subreddit by
the way
a very important warning just a warning
to all of you thinking about signing up
so the other day i was listening to one
of david's streams during a trump press
conference when i heard the coupon code
i nearly got into an accident shocked at
the obscenity of how much of a discount
it gave i had to pull over and sign up
so far so good i remember david warning
that the discount was so insane that it
might not be legal in my state i forgot
to check and make sure it was legal
before signing up
big mistake not long after merging back
onto the highway
i saw the police lights flashing around
me flashing behind me i pulled over and
sat nervously waiting for the officer to
approach
do you know why i pulled you over the
officer asked irritably
because i used the coupon code 20 20 now
i replied
timidly what in the are you talking
about your tail light is out he
responded almost irritably
i was lucky it was a routine stop had i
been arrested for using the coupon code
i might not have been able to post bail
for how much they for how much they'd
have
me locked up for what does it all mean
absolutely
nothing everyone needs to go out and
vote in november
perfect story pitch perfect um that is
just one of the things on the subreddit
so the messages here are
uh this is a fan fiction of sorts yes
join the subreddit at davidpakman.com
reddit and maybe as importantly
wow a lot of camera problems grab a
membership on my website
joinpakman.com a couple of people who
have david
tozier just signed up and alan gourley
new members number one and two at
joinpacman.com
boom look at that and we may actually
run out of memberships it could happen
we could run out and then we would have
no memberships left
that would be very very ugly so the
importance of voting
okay i'm gonna show people something
very very powerful here
i have here today my absentee ballot
okay now i'm not going to do anything
illegal or
possibly illegal like i think you're not
supposed to fill it out on camera
you're not supposed to show your
completed ballot
this is an absentee ballot okay as it
says here
state election official early absentee
ballot in spanish election
estate you understand papelette official
absentee we all need one of these okay
i'm going to be filling this out and
hand delivering it
to a dropbox i will film the delivery
of the dr at the dropbox uh we all must
do this
okay this is no joke tomorrow on the
program i am going to
show you how if you compare we are
currently
um what is it seven is it
i think seven is it no it doesn't make
sense 22
however many days out we are right now
from the election
okay if you look four years ago
at pennsylvania wisconsin and michigan
hillary clinton was polling better than
biden is today in those three states
so i know that we can say a popular vote
nationally biden's crushing i get it
we can say oh my god california biden's
gonna win by even more than hillary won
great
electoral college okay electoral college
if you look at those three states it's
not so good all right so we're going to
talk about that tomorrow also i have
here
one of my tomatoes okay i've never
introduced elements of produce into the
streams
but i did post today as donald trump has
arrived
i did post to my instagram today my haul
i pulled all of my large green tomatoes
because it is going to be frosting soon
and i'm going to be hand ripening these
indoors in a box
this is a beautiful tomato and
i believe that it will ripen poetically
as we approach election day and
hopefully on election day we will have
not only good results
but if we do i will take this tomato
which i will keep here in the studio
i will slice it up i will put oil salt
and pepper on it and we will enjoy this
tomato it will be red
by election day together all right guys
so this is from pakman farms
and it's going to be joining me maybe i
could even
put it somewhere in view and you will
see it turn maybe here
hold on right there yeah if i could
somehow secure it right there and then
we will see it ripen as the days go and
then hopefully we will have good
election results on
november 3rd and i will slice this up
and eat it with you guys
it'll be really really great so that was
instagram
make sure you were following me on
instagram very
very important as donald trump has
arrived very good
okay uh other important
things to mention uh oh jeremy schroeder
has just signed up at joinpacman.com and
is new member number
three today which which i very much
appreciate other super chats coming in
oliver wilde says david have you heard
about the gop allegedly staging
fake official ballot boxes to further
suppress votes what are your thoughts
i bookmarked the story over the weekend
and i will
comment on it tomorrow let me say a few
twitch
thank yous very much appreciate crazy
hawaiian in
pa for this sub hex
on songs 1658
classic tone daka dune join
voice please boy meets
mini combo carl and a lot of other
really great people very much appreciate
that
uh what other super chats do we have
here
david pac-man says david your hair looks
great as always keep up the good org
thank you well i showered today i wanted
to take it seriously
richard says we are about to appoint
serna joy waterford to a lifetime
appointment to the scotus are we totally
screwed
i'm sorry i i don't know the reference i
apologize
chakuseki says do you think trump has
overcome his lung spurs or will he
continue to make excuses
about god's gift of covid yeah we're
going to hear a lot of excuses oh that's
from uh
from handmade i don't remember that
character sermon joy waterford
tim of the rosebush says do you think
trump's forward awkward posture is
because he's trying to use his fancy
jackets to cover up his belly
i've been told that it's because he's
using lifts
that's what i've been told all right i
am going to debut now
very very strongly for you guys a new
single
from joseph woodward this one is called
she goes to the best college this is a
remix of me
interviewing trump and trump talking
about how he would date ivanka all right
let's listen to it as we see trump's
arrival
the newest single from joseph woodward
let's go to the phones
at six 617-830-4750
um let's see let's first go to
uh oh you know who's on the phone donald
trump is holding on and last time
it was off the rails and that that
intrigues me i'm in an off the rails
sort of mood
what's going on number one i'm in love
and you're in love we're all in love
together and when this happens
is this like parents is it siblings
cousins what like generation relative to
you is i've said that if ivanka wanted
my daughter perhaps i'd be dating her
hold on let's slow down because there's
a lot there let's really think it
through
she's got the best body yeah she made a
lot of money as a model a tremendous
amount and then she went cold turkey and
gave it all up because she had to go to
college because i wanted to go to
college
she goes to the best college she goes to
work
let's take a step back let's address a
couple different things
it ultimately the answer is really in
you
in the sense of what do you want your
relationship
to look like with these family members
right because
i i could give you advice that would
smooth things over
but to make you feel like you're
depressed i'm not looking bad for
anybody
well hope yeah i mean just work on being
a normal person my friend i'm gonna let
you go
david you're born a certain way and
doesn't really change that much
okay i don't believe any of it that's
all the time i have for calls today
so that was a really crazy day when
donald trump called in and said he would
date ivanka and of course just so you
know
that is the same joseph woodward who
created this masterpiece
to make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
[Music]
convalescent flows from strong
antibodies
from the blood of recovered patients to
help
joseph has also even promised new
material by the end of the week so we
may have something very very special for
you guys by
uh maybe by thursday i don't know i you
know you can't
you can't force creativity and joe joe
woodward knows that better than all of
us
but maybe we will have something new for
you guys by the end of the week
okay a couple of other super chats oh
wait did i have anything else here
i think that's it no i showed you my
tomato
and my absentee ballot um
yeah i think that's most of what i had
okay
richard cervelo says over under on trump
collapsing live on stage
no i don't think that's going to happen
i don't think so we
i will be curious to see whether he's
struggling to breathe all right
new members signing up let me say thank
you to michael mashuk who is new member
number four today
hugh josol we have like 10 members with
that name
it's not funny anymore but i love the
support is new member number
five today laura layton
is new member number six so that is
listen we are getting down to the wire
here we are doing
four or five streams a week i am asking
you
uh to grab a membership at
joinpakman.com we we really do
appreciate it it's the number one
primary funding source for the show you
know if you look at youtube funding it's
like an ekg
you know you look at twitch it's like an
ekg you look at facebook it's not even
you would have declared the person dead
for periods of time
with facebook revenue okay membership is
the way
and i would love for you to grab a
membership at joinpakman.com we have a
very modest goal of 25 members
and 2020 now as you can see as as a
coupon code
saves you 66 percent if you see the
normal prices and you say
beautiful normal prices are great don't
even bother with the coupon code
if you want the coupon code it's not
means tested
it's available to anybody who wants it
and you'll chop
66 off the price of your membership okay
and i will
be thanking folks throughout the stream
and hopefully we will
fill this entire bar you know we had 338
during the first debate i think we can
do 25
i sort of have faith in people that's uh
that's my instinct
patricker says i know there was no show
today but your website lists an episode
it's from
july 14th uh yes it is
um it's a rerun so we do re-runs on days
off
brendan kiernan says orange man
unironically bad
exactly exactly lauren kimball says
today
tomorrow is the last day to register to
vote in kansas
important deadline very very important
deadline
these are super chats i'm reading by the
way on youtube
let me see what else we've got i missed
a couple here
lee says do you think trump is paying
all those nuts to be there like they did
people at the white house yesterday
no i don't think so i don't think so
eric bob says hi bro hello michael
foster says one could even say that
those are perfect tomatoes this will be
a perfect tomato by the time
it's all said and done uh oh hold on
i do have a situation going on outside
there's a really crazy situation hold on
i gotta text my girlfriend
uh yeah we've got a crazy situation
i uh i participated in a um documentary
recently and the person who
is producing it sent me an alcohol
delivery of some kind
and they're calling me constantly
because they want to deliver it
uh i'm just telling my girlfriend what's
going on because i'm not going to be
alcohol delivery here
long story we'll explain
later yeah i mean she's not going to
know what's going on but
what can i do a lot happening a lot
happening right here
okay chaka seki says the front row of
the rally is going to be more
soaked with covered spittle than the
splash zone at z
at sea world it's going to be a whale of
a time
well said jonathan warden says hey
dvd i was trying to watch the members
video for today
it took me for one for july 17th yeah
it's we we were off for columbus day
today so we've got a repeat
james montalbano says the issue i'm
guessing you mean of the memberships the
issue is not one of legality but of
morality
offering such disgusting vile membership
discounts degrades not only david but
his audience
yeah i am degrading myself in front of
people by offering such strong
discounts but i want people involved
it's that it's that simple okay so for
example
kevin ivasku is new member number seven
beautiful antoine valliere lavoy
is number eight uh what else do we have
jerry souza is number nine
michael maffei is number 10.
those are just some of the names i'll be
mispronouncing this evening
as we wait for donald trump chase
axelsson says how do republicans pass
off their nationalism as patriotism
it's very strange how obvious it is well
it's not obvious to half the country
that's how they pass it off
lori travel says i went to a trump rally
all i got was the stupid maga hat
and covid 19.
alexander gomes says david please
organize an
unfollowed trump from twitter day
hitting his ego is the only thing that
works kinda
it's not even worth it this is what
matters right here okay
this is my absentee ballot which i will
be filling out tomorrow
and uh bringing oh there is a question
three that's interesting i thought there
was not
oh okay it's all right well yeah i mean
i'll go with a yes but
still um it's non-binding i will be
dropping that off
tomorrow and that's what really matters
gregory shavers says the new single
is low-key kinda lit yeah very very nice
work i i debuted a new single earlier
today
from joe woodward really really good mj
likes it says wow this is a hit
should be an ad to air all over the u.s
i still love the plasma one the best
yes since we have time some of you may
have missed there's now the
second song is don't be afraid of it
listen to this one
nobody that's a leader would not do what
i did
and i know there's a risk there's a
danger but that's okay
this one's trippy
i just left the world to read medical
center
this one gets really good and i learned
so much in moroni virus
don't be afraid of it you're going to
beat it we have the best
medical equipment don't be afraid of it
i felt great like
better than i have been a long time be
afraid
i didn't feel so good don't
be afraid of it you're going to beat it
we have to put on a virus
don't be afraid of it and now i'm better
maybe i'm immune i don't be afraid
don't let it dominate don't let it take
over your life be
afraid of it don't let that happen
you're the greatest country in the world
you're afraid of it
and your leader i had to do that i knew
there's danger do it but i had to do it
right but don't let it dominate your
lives get out there
be careful we have the best medicines in
the world
and it all happened very shortly and
they're all getting approved
right and the vaccines are coming
momentary
[Music]
this is my favorite
yeah so anyway that's the second uh fro
we're going to have an album here before
we know it it's going to be amazing
okay other super chats coming in i do
want to try to get to them i also want
to say thanks to
stark for machines for gifting a sub on
twitch mercenary
says good luck with you key election
captain flasher says uh
hell yeah go america very strong message
and a lot happening as we await donald
trump deretend says
i'm on boston time in the uk thanks to
david vote
must vote chase axelson with a message
in hebrew which i i'm not going to go
as rem as as uh nostalgic as that would
be to hebrew school days
i'm not going to do that right now
uh let's see other super chats coming in
oh i don't want to miss some hold on a
second
uh where did that go okay here we go
oliver says i predict the three second
coughing bout if his speech lasts more
than ten minutes well i do think that
the speech is going to be
uh maybe shorter than some others as we
see donald trump descend now
i don't know that this will be a super
long speech because of trump's cough but
we will see
he could also be on a very powerful
cough suppressant today
i don't know sean says i'm sure you saw
the regeneron drug was created with the
help of embryonic stem cells how wild
thank you for the content yes
very hypocritical of course pat says
what is that amy's covid test results
i'm sorry i don't understand that
naruey good girlfriend david how could
you
nick says david what do you think about
the documents that trump is asking
pompeo to release do you think that
might have an effect on the election
i don't know if you're referring to
hillary's emails which i don't think
will affect the election or something
else
uh we will we will only we can only wait
and see
we can wait we can vote wait and see
let's see what's happening audio wise
yep so we gotta just keep waiting that
ghastly says trump said closure equals
alcoholism
exhibit a david p
jordan noonan says weird alcohol
delivery flex
i don't even know what you're talking
about
citrus says do you think trump was so
outlandish in the first debate because
he couldn't have he could have been on
steroids
anything is possible is trump tossing
shirts now
is it this is like a sporting event oh
my god
trump's throwing shirts out to the
audience this is insane
thanks to michael mance who's new member
number 11 on my website joinpakman.com
frank saldivar is new member number 12.
lisa murphy number 13. this is now like
a cheap concert okay
eric melky is number 14 on my website
joey howly is new member number 15.
we will keep moving the bar as donald
trump
speaks and gets ready to speak uh
hinging forward at the waist and
something that seems
to defy gravity quite frankly but
uh trump is there and
it seems like upper trump let's listen
oh my god the volume is so low
it's great to be with you thank you it's
great to be back
i hear some struggle in the voice
already honestly
that's a lot of people
you know our competitor sleepy joey had
a rally today and practically nobody
showed up i don't know what's going on
it's called the pandemic
sleepy joe but it's great to be back in
my home state
florida to make my official return to
the campaign trail
this is insane i am so energized by your
prayers and humbled by your support
we've had such
incredible support and here we are
you know he sounds hopped up yeah dex
powerful decks but we're going to finish
we're going to make this country greater
than ever
before thank you thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
we've made tremendous progress if you
look at
what we're doing with therapeutics and
frankly cures
we've made tremendous progress and i
said to my people
we are going to take whatever the hell
they gave me and we're going to
distribute it around to hospitals and
everyone's going to have the same
damn thing impossible
[Applause]
we've all endured a lot together and we
are doing
better by far than we ever did in 2016
the enthusiasm is greater the spirit is
greater
we're going to have if it's possible an
even
greater and more important victory than
we had just four years ago
that i doubt that i doubt
and nobody ever said this fight was not
going to be a hard one
but we will make it like you've never
seen before
we are more successful now than we've
ever been before
our military is rebuilt take a look at
what's going on with our economy i hate
to say to the fake news
we're about to hit another stock market
record
401ks it's funny seeing people cheer for
a stock market that they have no stake
in whatsoever
not a nice guy by the way i have to be
honest not a nice guy you know people
say oh he's such a nice guy
he had a very bad day today he had a
very bad day you saw what happened
if i ever had a day like he had today
then say it's over
what happened today now biden had a bad
day
he forgot mitt romney's name
he didn't know what state he was in what
and he said today he's a proud democrat
running for the u.s senate now
you can can't do it it's the second time
can you imagine if i did that it's great
to be with you it's great to be a
wonderful developer from new york he got
his own
trump referred to himself as donald
trump recently what does he mean if i
did it
bad day he's got a lot of bad days
coming look look
we can't play games the one thing i know
for sure
president xi of china did us no favor
president putin of russia sounds high
looking around kim jong-un whatever
happened to the war we were supposed to
be in with kim jong-un
people stopped you from getting in
we have somebody running who's not 100
he's not 80 percent
he's not 60 percent we can't have this
as a country we can't have it joe biden
is also owned by the radical globalists
the wealthy donors the big money special
interests who shipped away your job shut
down your factories threw open your
borders
and ravaged our cities while sacrificing
american blood and treasure
in this ridiculous endless war set of
endless wars that we've been in for a
long time
19 years they're all coming back home
you know that right
they're all coming back home our great
warriors our great soldiers
okay the corrupt political class is
desperate to regain their power by any
means necessary
we're the ones standing in their way
we're the ones standing up for the
american worker the american family and
for the american dream and that's what
we're doing there's that populist
rhetoric
that went nowhere beautiful evening in
florida oh do i like florida did we win
florida last time was that beautiful
we wanted you know everything i hear
we're winning by a lot then you turn on
the fake news they say
the polls are tied in florida i don't
get it i don't
we had the same thing last year remember
four years ago we had the same thing
we're going to lose florida they said
four years ago by five points
they called that thing so early in the
evening we won by a lot
and we're winning by a lot more now than
we were
four years ago you could be right guys
we gotta vote
we gotta make 22 days from now we're
going to
win this state we're going to win four
more years in the white house
we're going to make our country greater
than it has ever
been before
thank you man thank you this is the most
important election
in the history of our country and i used
to say it in 2016. i'm sorry at the time
i thought it was
this one is now these people are crazy
we have to win
those people most important we've ever
had
biden has made a corrupt bargain
exchange for
his party's nomination he's handed
control to the socialists the marxists
and the left-wing
extremists and you know that there are
none he's got no strength left he's got
no power left he's got nothing going
if he wins the radical left we'll be
running the country
and they're addicted to power and god
help us if they ever got it because we
would never have the same country again
i hope you couldn't make a comeback you
don't make comebacks from where they
take us
if i do not sound like a typical
washington politician
it's because frankly i'm not a
politician i'm embarrassed by the torah
i thought it was because he's high as a
kite
on decks and if i don't always play by
the rules of washington establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you and i fight harder than anybody has
ever fought for you
and i had a very nice life before this i
will tell you
a lot easier but i love this and i would
have never
ever changed because we are doing more
for this country
than any administration has ever done
despite the witch hunts and the phony
stuff that we caught them on now we
caught them cold and we'll see what
happens with that
just watch hot and cold what were the
crops right now i'm fighting to make
sure we eradicate the virus rebuild the
economy and save our country
from the radical left we're hitting
record stock market numbers
record 401ks record stocks record job
numbers
don't blow it don't blow it
like you did on the virus sleepy joe
wants to quadruple your taxes
you know one second literally impossible
how about where he gets caught again he
said oh no we're not going to give a tax
increase but we're going to terminate
all of the trump tax cuts
well that's two thousand dollars plus
child tax credits
plus all of the other things you're
talking about six seven
eight thousand dollars a year i don't
think florida's gonna be paying that
that is a massive lie per family
stunning lie
and you know if you add energy into that
we have energy at an all-time low
we're energy independent nobody ever
thought that was going to happen
[Applause]
and when you're paying less than two
dollars at the pump like you are
nobody ever thought you'd see those days
again and those days are here for a long
time if we're smart
we've been beating china we've been
beating everybody until the play came in
we were teaching china like they've
never did you see that weird interview
where trump said he was beating off all
these different things it was a bizarre
interview
and we're very soon going to be doing it
again we achieved all of this despite
the fact
that we caught them cold they were
spying on our camp
it's our campaign our campaign a
campaign my
campaign that was what we call a glitch
they were spying on our
campaign and illegally trying to take
down
a very very straightforward and legally
sworn-in administration right before the
fact they tried oh my god he's losing it
campbell and you know then they say
he just you guys know he has no idea
what he's saying with a friendly
transfer of power for four years they've
been trying to get us out of office
[Music]
four years they've been trying to get us
out but we'll take care of it all after
the election
we got him called we caught him called
cricket hillary list the crimes
and by the way obama and biden knew
everything that was happening okay just
will he call for their jailing now
he did it last week take care of it
after the election joe biden
and the democrat socialist but that
gives you another reason to go out and
vote we got to get in because we don't
they'll just sweep it under the rug
joe biden and the democrat socialists
will kill your jobs
dismantle your police departments
dissolve your borders you know that
release criminal aliens confiscate your
guns no more second amendment
these are all lies none of this is true
destroy your suburbs
and drive god from the public square
that's what's going to happen
you saw in the pledge of allegiance
during the democrat
national convention they took the word
gonna have to grab the door my friend
they said oh we made a mistake excuse me
and then it happened a second time we
said well i guess that wasn't a mistake
right by niren refuses to answer
questions on the packing of the supreme
court nobody even thought of that for
many many many decades and that's what
they want to do they can't get there
legitimately so they say that's all
right we'll just pack the court we'll
put a lot of
super lefties on the court and we'll
have a whole different country nope
not going to happen that way we're not
going to let it happen you got to get
out and vote
you know a lot of people said that i was
elected because of the supreme court
because i said i'm going to put
great conservative constitutionalists
great judges on the supreme court i
don't know if it's true
but if it is true it's more true now
than it was four years ago and you got
to get out and vote because they're
going to destroy our country
and they're going to destroy our u.s
supreme court and we can't let that
happen
but who would have thought we're on
number three you know other presidents
have never had any
they've never had any we're at three
already three and a half he has to be
stopped
and i will say this i will say this it's
driving them crazy
it's driving them crazy and amy is
fantastic a great intellect a great
scholar i think she's going to be a
fantastic
u.s supreme court justice real scholar
google people of praise as america saw
earlier today
in amy's opening statement in the senate
judge barrett a brilliant scholar who
will defend our laws our rights our
freedom and our constitution
like very few people would have the
capability of doing
the radical left is hell-bent on
destroying everything we love and
cherish
they're enraged and unhinged he used to
dance around the authoritarian dictator
language
now this is just mussolini dyed mango
color
we understand their cancel culture we're
not letting them cancel culture us at
all
we're proud of our country and we're
proud of our heritage
[Applause]
they want to punish the middle class
expunge every last trace of traditional
values
and replace the american dream with a
socialist
nightmare and that's no
venezuela and ruin the lives of hispanic
americans and all americans
hispanics and i want to thank the
hispanic americans down in florida you
have been so incredible
to trump that it was prompt
[Applause]
biden's agenda would be a catastrophe
for
florida seniors and by the way he's
reading super quickly and i don't know
if it's because
he's hopped up on steroids or because
knowing he's not feeling well he's
trying to get through it and leave
right as i came into office obama gave
the whole planet away to castro and i
said no thank you
we're not doing that that never happened
that's why we just got the bear pigs
award
that doesn't exist americans thank you
very much and a lot of them are here
thank you all can someone fact check
that i think he's
referred to the getting the bay of pigs
award before i think it doesn't exist
30 in medicare you know all about that
now biden is pledging
mass amnesty and federal health care for
illegal aliens now
we all have a heart and we all want to
take care of people
but what you're doing is you're telling
millions of people to pour up into our
country we're going to give you
education we're going to give you health
care
we're going to give you everything we
can't do it
we can't afford it we can't take care of
our own people we have to take care of
our people first he's got to be on
something he never talks or reads this
quickly
and if they let that happen you would be
decimating medicare and destroying your
social security
well i'm president no one will touch
your medicare
no one will touch or hurt in any way
shape or form
your social security remember he
proposed deferring social security taxes
which are what you is used to fund that
program
world has ever seen and we were there
last year
was the greatest year in the history of
the state of florida and i have to say
it was practically that way for almost
every state
in the union but it was florida's best
year
the year coming is going to be and
you're going to see a great third
quarter set of numbers coming out very
soon just before the election
so i'm putting myself on the spot the
third quarter numbers are going to be
record-setting phenomena
okay so the the truth is trump was given
the bay of pigs award
by some random group in 1999
and it has nothing to do with his
presidency that's that's just amazing
we promise and i will always put america
first you haven't heard that right
you haven't heard that from other people
under my leadership oh when it wasn't an
award he was endorsed by
bay of pigs by a group of bay of pigs
veterans
21 years ago okay no country in the
world has recovered the way we've
recovered economically or otherwise not
even
close and if you vote for me
prosperity will search normal life
that's all we want we want a normal life
we'll fully resume and the florida
tourism and hospitality industries that
i know so well will reach historic new
highs
highs like they've never reached before
terminator recovery delay the vaccine
prolong the pandemic and annihilate
florida's economy with a draconian
unscientific lockdown that's what he
wants to do the crowd seems bored
everybody behind trump is talking
amongst themselves did someone fall you
guys see how there's a commotion right
here what's going on
risk groups you know the older people
now everyone
i'm not an old person i'm very young and
i'm in such perfect shape there seems to
be something completely unrelated to
what trump's saying going on in the
crowd behind him you know i said that
the other day what do you do i said well
i'm very young and i'm in great shape
perfect shape and they said
donald trump misrepresented today again
he said he was in great shape and he's
very young
these people are the sickest of them
[Applause]
but the world health organization did
you see what happened they just came out
a little while ago and they admitted
that donald trump was right
the lockdowns are doing tremendous
damage to these democrat-run states
where they're locked out
sealed up suicide rates drug rates
alcoholism
death by so many different forms you
can't do that
and i want to just congratulate the
governor and everybody in florida you're
open
and open for business and doing great
basically every state is open right now
it's just like stephen king wrote he
went to the movie theater the other day
there were four people at like a
multiplex total four not four per
theater there were four people because
people are like i'm not gonna go to the
movies right now
but the idea that the states are closed
is wild good about it if you want to
stay stained
relax stay but if you want to get out
there get out
one thing with me the nice part i went
through it
now they say i'm immune i can feel i
feel so powerful i'll
walk into that audience
oh my god i'll kiss the guys and the
beautiful women
and um everybody he's high as a kite
guys
no but there is something nice i don't
have to be locked up in my basement and
i wouldn't allow that to happen anyway
i wouldn't allow it to happen when
you're the president you can't lock
yourself in a basement and say i'm not
going to
bother with the world can you guys
workshop some titles for the youtube
clip i'll do tomorrow about this
is this trump threatens to kiss audience
at degenerate coveted rally that seems
like the title
immune i don't know for how long some
people say for life some people say for
four months
i mean every time i think about it every
time i hear that we get shorter and
shorter and shorter because they want it
to be
as bad as possible but it's uh
it is a great feeling i want to thank by
the way walter reed medical hospital
johns hopkins these guys are incredible
you know we're 90 better now than we
were six seven months ago in terms of a
cure for people that get really sick
ninety percent it's incredible what uh
what's happened
and with children it's 99.9 you're gonna
be okay
you're gonna be okay 99.9 they have a
little better immune systems we just
learned that better than you have right
better than people are asking if i've
sped the video up this is live it's not
sped up
school's open we have to get our
businesses going back we have to get our
country
rolling and it is rolling you're going
to see that when the numbers come out
the biden virus plan and you got to
remember
he took h1n1 which he always calls n1h1
he gets it pixlr
i said no joe h comes first
but it's called the swine flu right and
his own person his chief of staff said
that he would it was a disaster the way
they ran it a much less lethal problem
but a disaster the way they ran it a
total catastrophe it was
so bad it was so bad and then he says
i'm going to tell him what to do but
when i locked down china he thought it
was a terrible thing he called me
xenophobic right
when i locked down which was in january
months
earlier than what he said then
ultimately he admitted i'm right but
then he said oh he should have acted
faster well
this was months later then he says i
should have acted nobody acted fast like
i did i also shut down lockdown europe
if you remember
and the bottom line is we saved millions
of lives when this first came out if we
didn't do a good job they predicted 2.2
million people would die we're 210
that's not if you didn't do a good job
that's if you if you do nothing
who could get away with doing nothing
escape they allowed it to escape
china but 2.2 million people would have
died
just remember that just remember that a
fact they don't like talking about
i have such respect for the people of
this country the way they've handled it
it's been
an incredible it's been an incredible
love fest together that's really what i
spent
he may be euphoric from the decks that
actually may be what's going on
people who whose family members have
died whose friends i've lost friends
i've lost friends
thank you very much thank you very much
blacks for trump making their presence
known maskless like the entire group
behind trump
[Music]
thank you
thank you you're going to love me even
more you're going to love me even more
because we're
years ahead on vaccines and they're
going to be distributed very shortly
i mean frankly we're seven months in but
years ahead
i wanted to be before the election don't
let it be but we have great vaccines
coming
johnson and johnson moderna pfizer
i mean we have great great things
happening with the vaccines
i think even greater with the cures and
with the therapeutics
and maybe it's why i'm here with you
maybe it's not i'm not sure
i know one thing i was very happy to
take it that i can tell you
but through operation warp speed we're
on track to have 100 million vaccine
doses before the end of this year
and they'll be delivered by the military
and they're all set to go
they're waiting for it waiting for final
approval
and that vaccine will end the pandemic
but we're also launching a historic
effort to bring your medical supply
chains back home
in 1996 joe biden voted to obliterate
puerto rico's thriving
pharmaceutical industry remember 24
years ago
biden had a position he no longer has
vote trump
he cut it out he sent puerto rico
into a nosedive like nobody's ever seen
before
so we're bringing it all back and we're
bringing it back to florida too we're
bringing it all the way back
[Applause]
taking our jobs away from china we're
bringing them back from china i'll
reverse biden's catastrophic decision
we'll bring it all back the drug
industry is coming back into puerto rico
coming back into
by the way pennsylvania coming back into
north carolina
south carolina georgia coming back into
michigan coming back into ohio we're
bringing it all back
last month i also announced an
additional 13 billion dollars in
disaster relief
for puerto rico and for florida have i
taken care of florida
all right guys this actually is worthy
of i will offer mercy bans if people
want a mercy ban so they don't have to
see these future events
just ask the moderators they'll they'll
ban you it and it's it's not a sign of
aggression it's just mercy
senator's great they're always called
and ask you for money but i guess that's
what they're supposed to be doing
and i'm always giving it when it comes
to florida the panhandle got hit really
hard over the last two years we took
care of the panhandle
so days ago i was honored to receive the
endorsement of the governor of puerto
rico can you believe that
right wanda vasquez
garcette vazquez and she was so nice
they were also
joined by several great puerto rican
community leaders
jay rosario gabe ruiz uh-oh
daisy lopezid myra guzman koslow and
candidate for congress dr leo valentine
please i like guzman
that's a good one he got the guzman
endorsement
who's he taught what's he doing
[Applause]
if anybody i i the number of mercy band
requests went up after that
pronunciation
okay you better vote for me puerto rico
you better vote
but i'll always be fighting for puerto
rico it's very unfair the way
they were treated by democrats and
while biden will surrender your jobs to
china your
country and your fellow politicians and
i have a lot of great ones right here
including your governor
wow
but we're never gonna surround we will
never
allow ourselves to even think about
surrendering to the left
wing mob they're on the run they're on
the run
better not have them have a little bit
of a victory because if they have even a
little victory
it's not going to be good i'm bringing
our jobs back home and putting
violent criminals behind bars i'm
working with your political leaders
we've also
directed the fbi to immediately
investigate
the destruction of the teddy roosevelt
and abraham lincoln statues in portland
and to prosecute the offenders to the
fullest extent
of faith oh my god biden supporters
they're now directing like
small small property destruction
investigations
at the city level that's what he's
involved in now if he won
he may be the worst presidential
candidate in history and i got him
i got him
it actually puts more pressure on you if
you ran against a great candidate
there's actually less pressure you want
to know the truth thank you
thank you now we want to keep our
country great
we're bringing it to a level that it's
never been our military has equipment
the likes of which nobody has ever seen
no country has ever seen or made in the
usa
rockets missiles tanks ships
great stuff for the average american am
i right likes of which
no country has ever seen before our
nuclear arsenal is the strongest by far
in the world the strongest it's ever
been
and hope to god we never have to even
think about using it
right and the way you won't have to use
it is to have it
at our debate biden could not name a
single law enforcement organization that
supports him not one
[Applause]
and that's because and by the way did
vice president mike pence do a great job
did a great job
but it's because biden and harris that's
another great one
there was nobody so mean will he call
her a monster biden
than her nobody and so brilliantly i
said he can't pick her because nobody
treated him as badly
although i will say this uh had
elizabeth pocahontas warren got out
prior to super tuesday we would have had
bernie
instead but i'd rather it's weird to be
part of blacks for trump
and latinos for trump and sit there and
laugh as trump
uses the term pocahontas it's very
strange
for a year and a half he's against
fracking the day he gets the
nomination through a little luck because
she didn't get out
so she took all of bernie's votes right
but he gets a number this following day
he said i'm in favor of fracking but
he's not
and it doesn't matter because the
radical left will never let
pennsylvania and texas and oklahoma and
north dakota and
ohio never let them frack
that's over with but can you imagine and
the press you know which is fake
and corrupt the press never said have
you ever heard a mask
no have you ever heard a mass once well
wait a minute
for one year you said there will be no
fracking and he said it strongly right
you know read my lips right to use an
old expression read my lips there will
be no fracking that didn't work out too
well
so now weird how trump pretends to not
understand or doesn't understand the
difference between a policy of getting
off of fossil fuels for energy
versus i will ban fracking the day i'm
president wife of the mayor of moscow
bosco
not once have i heard these frauds back
there not once have i heard
the fake news not once have i heard them
say
a billion dollars if you don't change
that prosecutor you're not getting the
billion dollars
and then he goes whoa the prosecutor was
changed a prosecutor against his son
not once have i heard them talking about
that question
can you imagine if we did that
and on top of everything else the
democrat party declared war
on our great police and law enforcement
that's what it is
so i proudly received the endorsements
of the fraternal order of police
the national association of police
organizations
the national troopers coalition the
international union of police
association
the national latino police officers
associate
the florida police chiefs
and all of these incredible
organizations plus all over the country
and when i asked them
name one organization give me one
organization during our debate
where he was saved by the moderator
about four times
he couldn't answer it name one law
enforcement organization he couldn't
name one
then i said say the words law
enforcement just say it couldn't do it
you couldn't say it that's not true
we're joined tonight by a great group of
people warriors
really warriors he came to me
a couple of years ago he said sir i want
to run for governor i said ron
i don't know do they know you well
enough but he was a great defender and a
brilliant guy
harvard yale top of his class smart as
hell nobody knows how smart
don't tell too many people he likes to
catch you by surprise
but he's a great great guy he's been a
great friend i said all right i'll
endorse you
i endorsed him and the rest he went like
a rocket ship and he handled the
pressure
and and his wife casey is better than
him i've been saying it for a long time
governor ron desantis in case
roid rage great guy
great great couple great great couple
smart
brilliant sit down please uh really just
a great
great group of me please those people
are great and he surrounds himself with
incredible people with the exception of
course of representative matt gates
real disgusting oh matt gates
you talk about a warrior right ron what
do you think huh
matt gates is a great man a great
gentleman and what a future he has i
don't know if i'd swap it but i think i
might
great chat thank you matt thank you
thank you both for being here appreciate
it
john rutherford where is john john
thank you john mike waltz
mike trump's on a very powerful antibody
treatment known as
convalescent plasma gus
villarakis these pronunciations are just
stunning
congressional candidate somebody who's
supposed to be potentially a superstar
now we've heard that a lot
super spreader times it works out it's
going to in his case
scott franklin scott
thank you oh he's got the look he could
be that's good
that's good here good things got going
well how's he doing
ron he's doing good ron says you're
doing good good you got to win it
thank you very much uh kimberly where's
kimberly
completely off mike oh kimberly
guilfoyle spoke earlier i watched you
coming in speaking i said
that's a lot to follow yeah she was
actually great
i want to thank kimberly and finally
we're joined by a group of amazing
supporters who recently walked away from
the democrats
and will be voting for us we have a lot
of them
a lot of them and a lot of them in law
enforcement a lot of law enforcement
they were democrats
in some cases they left their parties in
other cases they just said no we're
voting for trump
i said why are you doing that we have no
choice i said you're right
you're right but nobody's been better to
law enforcement than i have you know
when i first came in
we gave away hundreds of millions of
dollars of
military equipment that was in storage
wasn't doing anybody any good it was
collecting dust probably paying rent all
over the place
that's probably why they had it come to
think of it but look how far that crowd
goes back
hey hey cameras will you please oh man
look at that
look at this guy
he's completely out of his mind
that's into those hangers
he seems to be struggling to breathe
i i seriously i think he's creating
diversions
to allow himself to catch his breath you
know these are the real pulls
so when did you hear about this meeting
like a day ago these are the real pulse
right
meeting the other guy gets out there and
he's
they work and work and work and 30
people show up they put them in those
crazy circles right
they only have the circles because
that's the only way they can fill up the
room it's true
but that's a fantastic group of people
thank you
same thing over here i wish the fake
news would turn the cameras you know uh
for a long time i didn't think the
cameras moved that way but then anytime
there was a little sign of problems they
could
twist around like a pretzel and i
realized that
they don't like to show those crowds but
that is a massive amount i don't know
how many people are here but you got a
lot
i want to thank you could be a hundred
thousand so this evening
we're also praying for all of the
families
on the florida panhandle affected by
hurricane sally and i will tell you ron
and
marco and everybody i'll tell you rick
everybody's been calling and calling
matt gates has been going
driving us a little crazy matt you could
take it a little easy
but that's what somebody that's good is
supposed to do right you're supposed to
call
but we take care of the panhandle and
we're doing it at a level that's never
been done before and i've done it i
think i can say
right from the beginning right i tell
the story about
ron desantis he came to see me he just
became hey guys just for contrast
let's see how hopped up biden is at his
event okay
this just ended the clock the last
fast train now they called the cella was
then called the metro
was at seven o'clock and i'd ride you
get outside the beltway
exit and you ride by all these
neighborhoods and i look in the windows
and wonder
literally sitting there looking out the
window
what what are those parents talking
about at that dining room table tonight
what are they doing before they put
their kids to bed right after they put
the
kid's bed and come back and sit down my
guess is
they're talking about the same things
that we talked about all across the
country
and we're talking about today they're
asking questions of one another as
profound as they are ordinary we're
going to be okay
we're going to make it what are we going
to do who's going to tell her we don't
have the money to go back to that
community college oh my
god biden's completely out of his mind
he seems to be on something guys i can't
believe it then listen to this well i've
watched i've watched
and you don't want much help either
you're proud people you're incredible
people
you put it back together but we're there
for you all the way and we're there
monetarily and we're there with fema
and i think ron fema's been incredible
right
yeah they've been incredible thank you
to fema we have a lot of fema people
here right over there
we've spent the last four years
reversing the damage
biden has inflicted over the last 47
years with
that ridiculous dumb thought nafta
tpp and china's entry into the world
trade organization
a disaster for our country
you know china is considered a
developing nation i stopped that
china is considered a development china
they're so wonderful they're developing
isn't that nice
now by being a developing nation they
get much more benefits than a nation
that's not a developing
so i said well we're a developing nation
too if they're a developing nation
and we just won you know this we just
won seven and a half billion dollars
from the world
trade organization he won it
and from the world health organization i
took this out
they said why'd you do that i said
number one they were wrong on everything
although they corrected themselves today
and they said i was right or the
lockdowns
but i said number two why are we paying
500 million a year
and china which has 1.4 billion people
is paying 39 million a year explain that
they couldn't explain it was very hard
to explain
so i took this out for that and other
reasons okay so we'll see what happens
with that
but these are the deals i could go over
hundreds of different things with you
and just common sense i mean common
sense what what we do
think of it world health organization
we spend we have 325 million people
we spend 500 million dollars
china spends 39 million dollars
and china dominates them i said does it
work that way anymore
does it work that way anymore i have to
tell you my green tomato from the garden
is making a lot more sense than what
donald trump is saying here
said much less money for decades our
politicians spent trillions and
trillions of dollars rebuilding foreign
nations
fighting foreign wars and defending
foreign borders
but now we are finally protecting our
nation rebuilding our cities
and we are bringing our jobs and our
factory
and our troops back home to the usa
but those dismal days of betrayal and
that's what we were we were betrayed
by our own politicians whether it was on
purpose or that they were just plain
stupid we'll come back with
unprecedented force if washington
democrats are allowed to take control
again we can't let it happen
you have got to get out and vote yes
finally we agree two points of agreement
with trump he says this is the most
important election of our time i agree
and we have to get out and vote
i agree forward the most radical
platform in american history including a
plan
to eliminate u.s borders oh that's
wonderful where's our border we don't
have one
just come in everybody come on in come
on in everybody
if you're a murderer if you're a rapist
if you're very very sick
with a disease that can spread all over
just come on in
you know we're up to almost 400 miles of
wall nobody talks about that anymore
well because the number changes every
day according to trump
and we now have the tightest safest
border in our country's history
but we're up to almost 400 miles it'll
be finished very soon
and it's top of the line it's exactly
what border patrol
wanted but by implementing nationwide
catch and release imposing deadly
sanctuary cities
nationwide nationwide they want
sanctuary cities that's what they want
i don't know what's fascinating is this
is not a political event like
people are waving in the background
people are talking amongst themselves
there's nothing about you know these
this is not about policy as we know
and part of this is about you know how
populist sounding rhetoric
can be completely devoid of actual
policy by by design
and donald trump certainly takes
advantage of that but like this is not
no political discussion is really
happening here where does it even
where does the thought process come it's
demented it would mean
the total nullification of all u.s
borders overwhelming every city and town
in america including this wonderful
place that we all love very much
under my leadership we achieve the most
secure border in u.s history
and we're finishing that wall it's going
to be finished and so beautiful wait do
you see that
where do you see that few more months
we're doing 10 miles a day and by the
way mexico is paying the haters so three
weeks ago trump said it was 390 miles
we're doing 10 miles a day but today
it's almost 400. can somebody pull out a
protractor and do the math on that for
me
and i said you have to do that otherwise
we're going to have to charge your
tariffs because we're not going to stand
for it when people are pouring into our
and we have the worst laws
because congress over the years has made
it so weak if you're a soldier and you
talk rudely to somebody they end up
giving you the electric chair
okay it's so horrible what mexico has
been great 27 000
soldiers we have see 27 now the electric
chair comment they'll put that
he's exaggerating he shouldn't do that
they are sick people
there but it is true we have 27 000
mexican soldiers guarding our border and
you know what they don't play games they
don't let them through
and if they do let them through we get
very angry with mexico
so mexico has been great the president
of mexico has been great we're putting a
border tax on
for cars and trucks that go across it'll
be much more than pay for our
wall street
crowd can barely even cheer for that
they know it's not happening they will
build the wall everybody thought there
was no way you know it's one of the
largest projects in the history of our
country
because you're talking about a lot of
miles 540 miles and then we may even add
some more into other areas where you
probably you know you have natural
barriers like mountains and rivers and a
lot of other pretty tough areas
but we may even add some more we're
doing so great with it 10 miles a day
and i want to thank
the army corps of engineers you've been
incredible
some of them are here they're very proud
people
one thing with the army corps they may
build it a little expensive but you
can't rip that sucker down and never
comes
that'll never come didn't people defeat
the wall with like a hundred dollars
worth of widely available hardware store
parts
name and you release them and you say
come back in three years to a court case
and nobody ever comes back except for
the really dumb ones they come back one
occasion
but nobody ever comes back they're in
our country and they could be murderers
and they could be all sorts of problems
and
we're not having that we ended it we
stopped asylum fraud and we've deported
20 000 gang members including ms-13
brought them back to their country
we brought them back to their country
we've now deported over half a million
criminal illegal aliens think of that
[Applause]
and outside of poorly run democrat
states and cities
you don't have crime in this country
this cri a country is doing
fantastically
and i call up governors in portland we
don't have crime i thought the whole
thing was we
crime is out of control but it's biden's
fault which is it
oregon i say we'd love to send some
people to help you out with oregon
origami to help you out with portland
we'll solve the problem in a half an
hour like we did in minnesota with
minneapolis
we'll solve the problem quickly remember
minneapolis was burning down day after
day and i'd call
let us come in let us come in anyway
they finally came in how long did it
take about a half an hour remember the
beautiful scene
they lined up they weren't socially
distanced but that's okay
they lined up then another line another
line then they just walked forward and
that was the end of that
and i think we're going to win the state
of minnesota because of it
i think that's not going to happen
hasn't been won since 1972
but it's looking like we're going to win
minnesota because of it because nobody i
mean what they did but i give the
governor credit
at least even though it was too long he
let us in
oregon we have to send in the troops we
will solve that problem in 30 minutes we
sent in the u.s marshals
recently when the man this horrible
human being shot somebody and killed him
in the middle of the street
two days went by three days went by said
why hasn't he been arrested
we sent in the u.s marshals in 15
minutes it was all over
15 minutes it'd be so easy to do
i mean can you imagine these people for
years and years it's been
it's been anarchy in portland for years
and years
but not for the republicans this is why
you cannot have the democrats and that
whole philosophy that whole craziness
you cannot have them involved in running
your country
we invested 2.5 trillion dollars in the
u.s military including funding
to save tyndale air force base
because who comes who knows tyndall who
is okay well not that big a group
that's not like a big group i can tell
you if you were in the panhandle you'd
be saying thank you very much
it was wiped out by the hurricane and
ron called and
a number of people called and uh mark
random people called trump rick scott
called
they all called they wanted to save
tyndall and we did it and now it's brand
new gorgeous and
really moving along well right tyndall's
moving along
beautifully we launched the first
new branch of the u.s armed forces in
nearly 75 years
called space force very important
right
you know for an administration if you
think of it so not for
75 years we've created a new force right
the army
navy air force marines some think of it
coast guard
and now we just created a new force
first time in 75 years
this is truly beyond parody and that's
peanuts
that's peanuts because we built the
greatest economy in history
we cut taxes more than any other
president by far in history
we cut regulations which i think is
maybe just as important as the taxes
that's why
our businesses are roaring back we've
done things that nobody else has done
nobody else has and these people back
here they don't even challenge me on it
which is shocking
usually you think they'll challenge you
even most people agree trump has done
things no president before has done i
don't but that's why nobody's
challenging him they agree it's just
which things
and we passed va choice and va
accountability for
obama passed that right
and we just got a 91 approval rating ron
91 approval rating by the vets
on the way we're running it never
happened before
that's never happened before rick never
happened before
we killed the leader of isis who was
trying to reform isis
because we blew it into oblivion
we killed al-baghdadi they were looking
for him for years and years and years
guess who got him we took out the
world's number one terrorist
and the mass murder of american troops
and many many people all over the world
kasim salamani he's dead
kasim solomani
i withdrew from the last
administration's disastrous iran nuclear
deal which was a catastrophe
president obama give us 150 billion
dollars and we'll give you nothing
give us 1.8 billion in green in cash
he gave him 1.8 billion in cash cash
that's when i realized how powerful the
presidency is when you can do that
what a horrible deal but we broke the
deal and i'll tell you probably the
first call i'll get
after we win the election will be from
iran dying to make a deal
because they're down 28 gdp nobody why
haven't they made the deal already
that'll be the first call i get
they cannot have a nuclear weapon
i kept my promise recognized the true
capital of israel and opened the
american embassy in jerusalem
idiotic man it's funny how people cheer
for that like i mean
it's of no practical value
other than being an impediment to peace
every president said they're going to do
that for many many decades they all were
going to do that nobody did it because
once they got in office there was a lot
of pressure on you not to do it i could
tell you i was called by every foreign
leader please don't do it please don't
do it
i tell the story i said listen uh tell
them i'll call them back in a couple of
days
then i did it i called them back hey
what's up i also recognize
israeli sovereignty over the golan
heights
52 years they've been working on that
they've been working on that for 52
years they couldn't get anything
every year people would fly in stay
whine dine have a good time and leave
nothing would happen
52 years i got it done in one day
and instead of these instead of these
endless wars we're forging peace in the
middle east
and peace without blood all over the
sand and you see what's happening
[Applause]
in fact a point that they didn't report
i re i've been i guess three or four
maybe now
nobel peace prizes can you believe it
four three
wait wait wait you watching tell the
story i told my wife
oh we're gonna have a great time we're
gonna watch television i just got
nominated for the nobel prize
and then i turned on the fake news story
after story
they talk about your weather in the
panhandle run it was a hurricane
devastating people's lives that we're
talking about remember when obama got it
right at the beginning and he didn't
even know why he got it it was the
biggest story you've ever seen
the last administration made a pathetic
one-sided deal with the castro
dictatorship
that betrayed the cupid people and
enriched the communist
regime they're not enriched any longer
my opponent stands with socialists and
communists he wants to give everything
away trump seems to think that his
getting nominated has the same
value as obama winning the nobel prize
now you could say obama didn't deserve
it but
he nomination versus win are two
different things
and venezuela in their righteous
struggle for freedom venezuela
last administration also negotiated
the terrible obama bi
santos deal with colombian drug cartels
they surrendered the narco terrorists
they surrendered totally gave up to him
and that caused illicit drug and illicit
drugs all over this country
joe biden even received the endorsement
of colombian socialist
gustavo petrol a former member of the
m19 guerrilla
organization and he took it because you
know why didn't the taliban just endorse
trump i mean that seems like a
silly game to play whoever he said no
he's a bad guy joe he's actually a bad
guy
under my administration we worked with
colombian officials to seize or disrupt
227 metric tons of poisonous narcotics
since april
and we're doing fantastically in terms
of
bringing it down 19 reduction
my heart will always be with the
colombian people and the people from
cuba
and the people of venezuela and
nicaragua and all of the people that are
so unfairly treated
and you'll see a lot of great things
happening what about the people being
unfairly treated right now under his
administration
47 years that's true
and now he's pushing the most far-left
agenda
ever put forward by a presidential
nominee or candidate
the biden plan would destroy social
security industry it wouldn't do those
things
now it is true that of any major party
candidate not not uh you know somebody
who ran in the primary but of any major
party candidate
biden's platform is the most progressive
that
is true it's just not socialist you
don't feel well okay go to the hospital
stand there for about four weeks
they'll shut down american energy shut
down fracking
and outlaw the private health insurance
plans of over 180 million americans who
love those plans
biden vowed to terminate our travel bans
on jihadist regions
and surge refugee admissions he agreed
to this with crazy bernie sanders
he's going to surge admissions into our
country by
agreed number 700 no thank you
opening the floodgates to radical
islamic
terrorism and i don't like to speak too
loud but we're not doing too badly are
we hud you know
he'll ban school choice he'll ban
charter schools
and he'll ban florida opportunity
scholarships which
is a big deal go further say he'll ban
florida just say he'll ban the
entire state in a second term i'll
provide school choice to every parent in
america
[Music]
a vote for republicans is a vote for
safe communities
great jobs and a limitless future for
all americans and i just have to say in
conclusion
over the next four years we will make
america into the manufacturing
superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all it's ending
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
which you're already doing in florida
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms your
second amendment
we have that i mean he doesn't need to
do anything about that that exists
crowd showing signs of life for the
first time in a while
we will strike down terrorists who
threaten our citizens and we will keep
america
out of these ridiculous horrible and
very very stupid
foreign wars against countries that
you've never even heard of
trump's never we will maintain america's
unrivaled military might
and we will ensure peace through
strength
we will end surprise medical billing
require
price transparency it's already signed
and it
takes place on january 1st and further
reduce the cost of
prescription drugs by 50 60 70 and even
80 percent
[Music]
[Applause]
air and social security and we will
always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions always
republicans will always protect
america will land the first woman on the
moon in the united states will be the
first nation to land
an astronaut on mars and it's going to
be very soon
i thought it was nars we will stop the
radical indoctrination of our students
and restore patriotic education
to our schools oh no
oh no look at this kid cheering for that
this kid's life is ruined that's sad
oh my god
this guy too really bad
we will teach our children to love our
country to honor our history
and always respect our great
american flag really gripping that
lecture
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
florida
so get out there and vote send in your
absentee ballot if you've requested one
be very careful a lot of shenanigans
going on you see what's happening every
day you're reading it
in person early voting begins next week
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors and get out and vote you
have no choice you have to do it
true you got to do it do it we're going
to win florida big we're going to win a
lot of states big we're leading in
arizona
we're leading in nevada we think we're
leading in pennsylvania we're leading in
north carolina
we're leading all over the place
[Applause]
we've got to have this be a big win from
tampa to tallahassee
from pensacola to miami and from
jacksonville to right here in sanford
we stand on the shoulders of florida
patriots
who gave their blood sweat and tears for
this beloved nation
we stand on the shoulders of american
heroes who crossed the oceans
blazed the trails settled the continent
tamed the wilderness laid down the
railroads dug out the panama canal
raised up the skyscrapers won two world
wars defeated fascism and communism
and from here in this beautiful state
landed our brave american astronauts on
the face of the moon
a lot of moon talk today has nothing to
do with trump but
we made america into the single greatest
nation in the history of the world
and the best is yet to come
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we're returning power to you
the american people with your help
your devotion and your drive we are
going to keep on working
we are going to keep on fighting take
that and we are going to keep for
president winning
winning winning
and when ron desantis comes to my office
in washington the magnificent oval
office
and he says to me sir sir sir routine
the people of florida they've won too
much they're getting tired of winning
i'm going to look at it i'm going to say
mr governor go back and tell him don't
worry about it
you're going to keep on winning winning
winning that's what they want to do
we're going to keep on winning winning
winning
because we're one movement one people
one family and one glorious nation
under god
and together with the incredible people
of florida
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
and we will make america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you florida thank you
very much
thank you
[Music]
okay and then donald trump let's see if
he does the dance where it looks like
he's
winding a hose sort of uh it's hard to
describe but it's a very very strange
thing that he does let's see if he does
do it
uh very very powerful event as all of
you can imagine donald trump i've never
it is the ener it is mania and i also
like the energy of desperation it does
seem like a desperate trump for sure
um but it is uh donald trump's first
event
since oh there it is there it is guys
there is this the uh
the um hoes uh rolling there it is
um trump's first event since having
the virus as we call it um
just extremely cringe-worthy in all
respects
in every single respect um
[Music]
and donald trump here with uh you know
blacks for trump on the stage
latinos for trump cops for trump women
for trump
um any number of different groups and
donald trump speculation running rampant
that donald trump was on some kind of
stimulant extremely fast reading
it is florida so i don't know that i
would make that much of the sweating
necessarily
um at a couple points seeming somewhat
short of breath but
those steroids will make you feel great
for a period of time
so no no surprise that donald trump
brought
a lot of energy throwing masks to the
crowd
when he came out that is that is
absolutely true there is trump doing his
dance
yeah so so he's continuing to uh
to go um
a number of different super chats coming
in oliver wilde says aggressive super
chat trump's post talk dance looks like
he's simultaneously disappointing
two invisible giants oh my god that is
aggressive that is very very aggressive
uh donald trump waving to the crowd as
you can see
and uh eventually oh look at look at the
the dancing is definitely a new thing
uh seems seems very has trump lost
weight is it possible that
while he was in hospital he actually
lost a bunch of weight he does seem
thinner to me
uh kind of interesting uh i mean being
sick will do that to you people with
coronavirus
many very oh god jewish voices for trump
that's horrible uh text
shalom oh my god that is i feel uh
embarrassed by that
people do with with cases of coronavirus
people will uh will sometimes lose
weight i don't know if trump has but
still
adhering to that stance hinging forward
at the waist as as many of you can see
uh donald trump did reportedly test
negative today
yes um that uh that that reportedly is
true as donald trump will make his way
back to his airplane people very very
like it's weird being excited to see
trump like this and to stand around
no masks as you can see i mean some
people on stage behind him had one this
one guy here has a mask
um but very few masks if you're even
willing to be here you're not really
interested in in reason you know so i
don't think we can go by much
by by just evaluating the crowd i don't
think there's very much
to gain from that let's see if the music
is still pumping
[Music]
yeah it's still going to go and then
donald trump eventually going to make
his way
back to the plane so that is that donald
trump's first
coveted rally as you can see people at
the bottom of our screen
eagerly moving towards the exits they
are ready to go
not interested in getting caught
apparently uh and what could be a little
bit of traffic on the way out people
sort of shuffling out they don't look
dejected
i wouldn't say but i mean
i don't know it's hard for me to say
because i'm not the target of such a
rally
but it's hard to imagine seeing that and
then saying wow that was really great
but i guess a lot of these people might
uh might believe that
so listen tomorrow i believe that prompt
has rallies the next two days tomorrow
night i have a college speaking gig
um where i will be taking questions much
like ben shapiro does but it will be via
zoom
because of coronavirus so tomorrow night
very unlikely that i will be streaming
but i may be back with you
on the wednesday rally biden event
and then my goal would be on thursday
to have um the the
i don't know if it will be town halls
for biden and trump
i don't know the full details yet i will
talk to my various contacts to see
what the copyright status is but i would
love to carry the two town halls back to
back for you
on thursday night potentially maybe
maybe maybe you know we will see
uh so that does it for me today i do
appreciate you joining me
we will be a played out today by the
newest single from joseph woodward
she goes to the best college i'll see
you guys very soon
let's go to the phones at 617-830-4750
um let's see let's first go to
uh oh you know who's on the phone donald
trump is holding on and last time
it was off the rails and that that
intrigues me i'm in an off the rails
sort of
what's going on number one i'm in love
and you're in love we're all in love
together and when this happens
is this like parents is it siblings
cousins what like generation relative to
you is i've said that if ivanka weren't
my daughter perhaps i'd be dating her
let's say hold on let's slow down
because there's a lot there let's really
think it through
she's got the best body yeah she made a
lot of money as a model a tremendous
amount and then she went cold turkey and
gave it all up because she had to go to
college because i wanted
to go to college she goes to the best
college she goes to work
let's take a step back let's address a
couple different things
it ultimately